Esta es la primera vez que James
stoltenberg el secretario general de la
alianza atlántica viene a kiev Desde esa
invasión a escala máxima ordenada por el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin en
febrero 24 del año anterior esta visita
sorpresiva llega en un momento en el que
Ucrania se prepara para esa
contraofensiva que supuestamente debería
comenzar con la llegada de la primavera
que ya comenzó hace casi un mes sin
embargo el clima Sigue estando bastante
malo en Ucrania como vemos hoy llueve en
kiev y esto se repite especialmente en
esas zonas del este y del Sur del país
especialmente en el don báez donde las
carreteras siguen estando pobladas de
barro y hace bastante difícil la
movilización de las tropas y esto se
suma a que Ucrania sigue todavía
esperando la llegada de más y más
armamento prometido por esos países
occidentales que parte de la alianza
atlántica se anunciaba que ya estaban
esos misiles Patriotas que están son
importantísimos en la defensa de Ucrania
también se asegura que los hombres los
militares entrenados para manejar este
armamento también están regresando al
país y así también empiezan a llegar
otro tipo de armas Como esos tanques
leopardos prometidos no solamente por
Alemania sino por otros países europeos
sin embargo faltan más por llegar
También faltan más hombres entrenados
tanto en Estados Unidos como en Europa
para realizar esa contraofensiva de la
que seguramente hablarán hoy tanto con
el presidente
boloñir selens que a él se le vio esta
mañana frente a la catedral de San
Miguel de las cúpulas doradas allá hay
una gran pared donde recogen miles y
miles de fotos de hombres que no
solamente han muerto en este último año
sino desde que comenzó esa invasión rusa
y esos ataques ya en el 2014